Êtes-vous obéissant ? Êtes-vous soumis ? Non ?
Bah ça c'est ce que vous croyez. Et c'est ce qu'on croyait aussi avant Milgram.
Salut ! Aujourd'hui pour ce jeudi du hors-sujet je voulais vous parler de l'expérience de Milgram.
Entre 1960 et 1963 Milgram et son équipe ont créé et réalisé un test de psychologie visant à mesurer le degré d'obéissance des gens.
Le principe était très simple, il fallait justifier une action en se référant à une autorité.
Pour l'expérience il y avait toujours trois personnes. La personne qui prenait le rôle du  chercheur scientifique. Et donc qui représentait l'autorité.
La victime qui était un comédien, un complice, je vais vous expliquer à quoi elle servait.
Et le sujet, c'est à dire la personne testée qui perpétrait les actions.
Il y a deux choses à savoir importantes : tout le monde se rencontrait au départ et tirait au sort
qui allait avoir quel rôle parmi la personne qui disait les réponses et la personne qui allait envoyer les décharges.
Oui, ils s'envoyaient des décharges électriques.
Le tirage au sort était bidon, il était pipeauté puisqu'on voulait que le sujet soit celui qui envoyait les décharges.
Et la deuxième chose à savoir, c'est qu'ils étaient défrayés mais il n'y avait rien à gagner. Il n'y avait pas de gain pour la personne qui était le sujet.
En clair il n'y avait pas de récompense au fait qu'il fasse les actions, et il n'y avait pas de représailles si jamais il décidait de ne plus les faire.
C'est très important de comprendre ça parce qu'on comprend en même temps qu'il n'y avait pas de vraie pression extérieure,
il n'y avait pas une pression du gain, il n'y avait pas une pression de masse via la foule, il n'y avait pas une peur des représailles,
c'était dans son libre arbitre qu'il faisait les actions.
La victime se mettait dans une autre pièce et elle devait répondre à une série de questions.
Le sujet, lui était devant une machine où il allait envoyer des décharges électriques.
C'est à dire qu'à chaque mauvaise réponse de l'autre personne, qui était comédien mais lui ne le savait pas,
le sujet devait envoyer en punition une décharge électrique.
Plus le nombre de mauvaises réponses s'accumulait,  plus les décharges électriques étaient fortes pour aller jusqu'à une dose mortelle de 460 volts.
Et histoire d'en rajouter un petit peu, au fur et à mesure de l'expérience quand la personne se prenait des décharges,
ou en tout cas simulait de se prendre des décharges,
on l'entendait hurler et demander à ce que cela s'arrête.
Sachant que la personne qui envoie les décharges ne subira pas de représailles, n'a rien à gagner, donc rien à gagner, rien à perdre,
est-ce qu'elle va continuer à faire ça ou pas ?
Quand Milgram en a parlé à des psychologues de l'époque, on lui a dit il y a peut-être un ou deux pour cent des personnes qui vont aller jusqu'à 150V.
C'est beaucoup plus que ça. Tous les participants sans exception sont allés au moins jusqu'à 135V avant d'arrêter.
Mais sans vous donner tout le détail, 62.5% des gens testés,
Soixante-deux virgule cinq pour cent (62.5%), c'est énorme,
sont allés jusqu'au bout, jusqu'au 460V.
Ce qui représentait l'autorité c'était donc le chercheur qui menait à bien le test.
Il n'avait le droit de dire que 4 phrases si la personne souhaitait arrêter.
Sa première phrase c'était : "Continuez, s'il vous plaît."
Cette simple phrase-là dans la majorité des cas a fait que la personne a continué tout le long.
Si la personne demandait une deuxième fois à s'arrêter, le chercheur avait juste le droit de dire : "L'expérience exige que vous continuiez."
Si dans le test, la personne demandait une troisième fois d'arrêter, il devait dire : "Il est absolument indispensable que vous continuiez."
C'est vraiment les phrases précises, exactes. Pas un mot avant, pas un mot après, pas d'autres discussion.
Il n'y avait que ces 4 phrases. Et la dernière phrase c'était : "Vous n'avez pas le choix, veuillez continuer."
Si à la quatrième phrase, la personne disait : "Non, vraiment j'ai pas envie."
Alors l'expérience s'arrêtait là, c'était bon.
Et sinon, la seule manière d'arrêter, c'était d'aller jusqu'aux 450-460V, qui est un choc électrique pouvant être considéré comme mortel.
62.5% des gens qui se réfèrent à une autorité quelle qu'elle soit juste parce qu'ils lui prêtent un pouvoir,
et se créent une pression eux-mêmes, c'est déjà beaucoup.
On s'est posé la question il y a quelques années : est-ce que ça pouvait être encore le cas aujourd'hui ?
Il y a une émission de télé qui a été fait là-dessus qui est un projet franco-suisse. Et j'ai retrouvé la vidéo de cette émission je vous la mets dans le descriptif.
Ils ont réessayé l'expérience de Milgram mais version jeu télé.
Durant des semaines et des semaines ils ont fait un plateau télé qui était censé être un plateau test avec toujours le même tirage au sort,
le joueur dans la cabine qui prenait les décharges et celui qui les envoyait.
Toutes les personnes qui y ont participé savaient que c'était un casting-test et qu'ils n'avaient rien à gagner.
Donc encore une fois il n'y avait rien à perdre, rien à gagner.
En 1960, 62.5% des gens sont allés au bout.
Et il y a quelques années seulement dans ce jeu télé, 81% des personnes sont allées au bout.
C'est à dire que si on mettais en scène le jeu de la mort réellement à la télé, les gens iraient au bout.
Encore une fois n'hésitez pas à regarder la vidéo, je vous mets le lien dans le descriptif. Elle est très intéressante, elle est passionnante.
Ça dure une heure et demie mais ça vaut le coup.
Au final Milgram il nous aura appris une chose : c'est pas qu'il faut forcément défier l'autorité ou les autorités en général,
mais il faut au moins garder son esprit critique pour remettre en cause l'autorité et remettre en cause le bien fondé.
En clair, c'est pas parce qu'on vous dit de le faire qu'il faut forcément le faire sans réfléchir à pourquoi on le fait.
Merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo, j'espère que ça vous a intéressés et que ça vous a plu.
Si c'est le cas n'hésitez pas à mettre un... pouce en l'air !
Allez-y.
Faites-le.
Il est indispensable que vous le fassiez.
Oui, et puis du coup personne ne va le mettre parce que vous voulez défier l'autorité.
N'hésitez pas non plus à laisser un commentaire, je les lis tous, toujours.
Evidemment vous pouvez également vous abonnez à la chaîne puisque le mental vlog c'est une vidéo par jour pendant un an.
Donc rendez-vous demain à 17h, ciao !